the Labour MP for Brent central John
Butler joining us from our westminster
studio your responsive responsibility as
well miss Butler yeah it is and it's
it's cool I accept that responsibility
I'm glad I nominated Jeremy I think it
was our duty as MPs to make sure that we
had as many different people on the list
as possible so that we could have the
widest possible debate in the party
you'd like him to win and I don't think
that Jeremy will win I nominated Jeremy
West Jim with respect yes but I'm
answering so the question is no no a
question is do you want him to win yeah
when I'm and I'm going to answer UK just
calm down so what I'm saying is I
nominate Joe I'm happy that I nominated
him I don't think he will win the person
that I'd like to win would be Andy do
you want him to win I'd like Andy
Burnham to win because I think Andy is
the leader that we need to take the
party forward and to actually unite the
party so I'd like Andy Burnham to win so
what was the point in voting for Jeremy
Corbyn to be on the ballot paper in the
first place because as I said right at
the beginning it was our
responsibilities as MPs to make sure we
had the widest possible debate as
possible it was only MPs that were
nominating the candidate so it was up to
MPs to say okay these are the people
that we have to choose from as a party
and I think it's important jeremy has an
important role to play within the Labour
Party to make sure that we define who we
are and Jeremy has a pivotal role in
that and he is doing an amazing job in
making sure that we have a debate
covering all aspects of the Labor Party
and what he's doing is he's making sure
that we don't forget our past as a
Labour Party but we redefine and make
sure we secure our brand if you like as
a party and I respect Jeremy a hundred
percent what's the point of putting
somebody on the ballot paper if you
don't want them to win Oh should I
repeat myself okay so what I'm saying is
that it was our responsibilities as MPs
to make sure that we had as many people
as possible we could have just nominated
two people and had to debate amongst two
people that work wouldn't have taken
into the spectrum of the of our party
and it's great and it's import
the Jeremy's on the list of that we have
a widest possible debris so it's good
that I mean I don't know you say the
politicians don't answer the question
I've answered it three times and then
you asking me the same question again
it's important I'm pleased I don't
regret nominating Jeremy and if he wins
I'm sure that he will make sure that we
mold the party in terms of where we are
and then I'm sure he'll do what's right
that's Jeremy Jeremy is cool Jeremy's a
cool guy and he knows what he's doing
and he knows what he's saying he wanted
to be on the foreign select committee
that's where his heart lies that's what
he really wants to do and I think he's
got an important role to play in that as
well Tony Blair doesn't agree and
neither it would seem does the Yvette
Cooper who says that she wouldn't be in
his shadow in her shadow cabinet
okay well that's Tony Blair and event
Cooper but Andy says that Jeremy would
be welcome in his shadow didn't he said
I would certainly not having Miss
Chancellor Shadow Chancellor but he said
he said Andy Burnham said that he would
have Jeremy any Shadow Cabinet don't
tell me that he didn't say it because
dude he started off with you he said on
the telly he's it he said on the telly
on Sunday on the Andrew Neil program
that he wouldn't have him as the Shadow
Chancellor okay so you might not have
him as the Shadow Chancellor but Kay
there are other positions dude I mean
there are other positions and there's
probably other positions that Jeremy
would want to be or do so there are
other positions in the Shadow Cabinet
than just one okay but he would be in
charge of the purse strings if you were
in government if Yvette Cooper was the
prime minister in charge of foreign
policy and that's where he's heart lies
so that would be quite a good position
for Jeremy to be in don't you think I
have no idea as far as mr. Blair is
concerned should he get involved in the
modern Labour Party I think I think Tony
Blair was a successful leader the Labour
Party he won three elections he has his
right to have a say like everybody else
he has one vote the same as myself and
the same as all party members and the
same as people have signed up as
affiliate they had one vote one vote and
that's it so he has one vote so you can
have you say you know I disagree with a
lot of what he said but I haven't heard
everything that he said but he only has
one vote that's the beauty of the system
that we have one member
one vote do you think the process that
the Labour Party has adopted for this
round of adopting the leader is the
right one
um I don't understand your question
sorry no no okay I'll let me ask you
again it's a different way of adopting a
leader of the Labour Party this time -
last time do you agree with it
yeah I think it's a good process I think
we're having a debate I think we're
having a we're having a serious debate
in the party and I think it's the right
thing to do because we have to have this
debate this is this is an internal thing
for the Labour Party we have to have
this abate debate we have to we've lost
two elections we have to make sure that
we are in place to win another election
that means that we have to have a
deep-rooted debate and that's what this
is contributing to a deep-rooted debate
so when we come out of this we will be a
stronger party and that's the most
important thing that we come out of this
United a stronger party to take on the
government and to make sure that you
know we win in 2020 and we try and undo
if we possibly get some of the damage
that this government is doing to our
country and to people who are working
these are people who are working this
government is hurting the people who are
working there trying to make sure that
they you know scrap with any rights that
they have to any legal regress to you
know to a pay rise you know Osbourne is
acting like a magician you know the
living wage is nine pound fifteen an
hour he's made it he's you know made it
seven pounds twenty effectively a pay
cut there's a lot to be done for this
government we have to be united to do
that and that's the process that we're
going through at the moment do you think
any of the other candidates should drop
out ahead of the vote no what that
doesn't make sense why would they drop
out ahead of the vote unless unless
everybody's united around one candidate
no the whole point is is that we have a
process we have and the elimination
process will come when we vote we have a
process we have a debate we have a
discussion if somebody feels is one of
the candidates feels then it's time for
them to drop out and put their support
behind another candidate then firm
enough but it's up to the candidate to
do that this is how a political
democratic process should work okay
great to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us on sky Diaz this
afternoon thank you